[Música]
ni una menos con ese lema comenzó hace
ocho años el movimiento que luchó contra
los feminicidios la idea se gestó en
Argentina tras el asesinato por motivo
de género de Kiara Páez una adolescente
de 14 años su novio Manuel mansilla de
17 La mató a golpes porque ella quería
tener el bebé y el no el 3 de junio de
2015 miles de mujeres salieron a las
calles de Buenos Aires a protestar con
el tiempo la marea verde y ni una menos
se extendió por toda América Latina qué
ha pasado desde entonces que cambios han
logrado y cuáles Todavía faltan para
analizar el tema hoy nos acompaña en
nuestro estudio Cristina Rosero abogada
senior del centro de derechos
reproductivos y desde Ciudad de México
se conecta Brenda Velázquez Montiel
oficial de comunicación e incidencia en
el programa libertad y ambiente seguro
de la ong feminista balance a ellas
bienvenidas y a ustedes les recuerdo que
también hacen parte de se debate pueden
dejar sus comentarios y preguntas en
Twitter Facebook e Instagram donde nos
encuentran como arroba
franz24-1 al piso es pueden comentar con
la etiqueta numeral el debate f-24 y en
Twitter yo estoy como arroba maríacle
Aguirre no olviden que todos los
contenidos del debate están disponibles
en Apple podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
quiero comenzar entonces dándole la
bienvenida a Cristina Gracias por
acompañarnos Cristina Cuál es el balance
de que usted hace de ni una menos bueno
sin duda el hecho de que ni una menos
haya existido en Argentina creó un
movimiento social alrededor de todo el
continente alrededor de estos temas no
se trata de que haya sido un tema
absolutamente nuevo las organizaciones
de mujeres llevaban muchos años
denunciando este punto pero el gran
logro de las argentinas fue el hecho de
Por una parte crear una movilización
social más informada alrededor de este
tema y también crear ese movimiento
social como una respuesta al hartazgo de
la constante violencia contra las
mujeres que hizo también y se y se dio
en muchas maneras en medidas o cambios
legislativos o en cambios sociales
alrededor de este punto Entonces si bien
no se trata de un tema nuevo y la
violencia contra la mujer ha venido
dándose a través de los años por la
discriminación estructural que sufrimos
las mujeres y las niñas sin duda
más o menos es un hito internacional que
hace que el tema de los feminicidios
salga la luz de manera más evidente y
que haya un llamado mucho más claro de
la sociedad a que las autoridades y los
Estados tomen medidas para poder
prevenir y atender a aquellas personas
que son afectadas por la violencia de
género y esto sin duda tuvo un impacto
en otros países del continente y sin
duda seguirá teniendo un impacto de aquí
en adelante como lo hemos visto con
otros fenómenos como el de la marea
verde y ya vamos a ver precisamente ese
impacto usted habla de que el hartazgo
contra la violencia de género no es
nueva no comenzó en 2015 con el caso de
Kiara Páez y tampoco la violencia de
género como tal comenzó entonces Brenda
Le quiero preguntar a usted primero que
todo darle la bienvenida y preguntarle
cómo es que el caso de Kiara Páez
dispara este hartazgo que venía de
tiempo atrás
si en Ciudad de México y en particular
en la República Mexicana pues ya
teníamos consciente el el problema de
los feminicidios desde
los asesinatos en Ciudad Juárez a
diversidad de mujeres y las
características específicas con que
estos asesinatos eran efectuados
entonces la exigencia por el alto a los
feminicidios y por el respeto a la vida
de las mujeres y a tener vidas dignas
como estaba ya puesto sobre la mesa y lo
que viene a ser ni una menos es un eco
de estas voces que están luchando y que
continúan luchando porque el feminicidio
y la violencia hacia las mujeres vaya en
declive y por algún momento se detenga y
como ustedes bien lo han señalado es un
movimiento regional que se ha visto en
toda América Latina esto contrastado con
los datos de ONU América Latina es la
segunda Región del mundo con más
feminicidios feminicidios recordemos son
los asesinatos que ocurren a causa del
género es decir a las mujeres por ser
mujeres no por otro hecho diferente y
América Latina en 2021 tuvo
4.473 feminicidios al menos de los que
se conocen eso para que hagan unas
cuentas en sus casas es 12 mujeres
asesinadas por ser mujeres cada día la
única región en el mundo que supera esa
cantidad de feminicidios es África Le
quiero preguntar a usted Cristina Qué
hace de América Latina una región tan
violenta y tan peligrosa para las
mujeres sin duda la la causa estructural
que crea los feminicidios tiene que ver
con la discriminación contra las mujeres
digamos Este no es un hecho nuevo las
corrientes feministas las organizaciones
de mujeres lo han denunciado hace mucho
tiempo el feminicidio es la forma
extrema en la cual se presenta la
discriminación contra la mujer es la
manera más grave en la cual esa cadena
de discriminaciones se convierten en un
asesinato pero un feminicidio se puede
empezar a desde una relación en la cual
un hombre tiene una serie de
concepciones sobre las cuales considera
que la mujer es de su propiedad que
puede controlar la manera en que esta
mujer se comporta que puede tener un
absoluto control de cuáles son las
decisiones de la vida de esta mujer y
como eso se va viendo en lo que mal
llaman en algunos ocasiones
micromachismos o micro violencias que se
van presentando digamos de manera diaria
o o permanente en la cotidianidad y que
en muchos casos normalizamos no hay
casos en los cuales un chiste machista
puede parecer que es una exageración de
denunciarlo pero lo que nosotros hemos
visto con el tiempo y lo que se ha
denunciado a través de las décadas es
que esas pequeñas cosas van sumando a
una cultura en la cual se tiene poco
respeto por la vida de las mujeres y que
los hombres siguen pensando en una
superioridad que finalmente se termina
presentando como una serie de
discriminaciones que pueden generar esa
violencia entonces en últimas las causas
estructurales se siguen presentando y es
el hecho de que la discriminación contra
las mujeres se tiene que seguir
combatiendo y de esta manera podrá
controlar mejor la violencia que se
presenta contra ellas entonces muchos
organismos de Derechos Humanos como la
Comisión Interamericana los comités de
derechos humanos de Naciones Unidas han
hablado de esta relación entre la
discriminación contra las mujeres y como
esto se se lleva una forma de violencia
pero mientras no sigamos digamos
mientras no tengamos unos elementos de
prevención que ataquen ese punto central
las formas de violencia todavía van a
seguir presentándose y va a ser difícil
seguirlas atajando por lo tanto esto
empieza por un cambio cultural que vaya
desde esta causa estructural para poder
transformar aquello que es lo más grave
que son los feminicidios Entonces
nosotros podemos estar hablando de unas
medidas más específicas de atención a
las víctimas las medidas urgentes que
las personas que son Víctimas de este
delito necesitan Pero esto es apenas una
parte de las transformaciones que
culturalmente y socialmente necesitamos
para ir hacia una sociedad en donde
menos mujeres sean atacadas por estas
causas todo apunta un elemento muy
interesante y es el cambio cultural que
se necesita para que las mujeres sean
respetadas y cese la discriminación
mucho antes de que llegue al caso
extremo de ser un feminicidio Brenda ni
una menos ha contribuido a ese cambio
cultural que se necesita
sí sin duda entre ni una menos y otros
movimientos que se han gestado es lo que
se ha contribuido es que las
organizaciones de mujeres se fortalezcan
justo para frenar la violencia como lo
mencionabas entre datos estadísticos al
menos en los últimos cuatro años en
Ciudad de México los feminicidios no han
disminuido tenemos que en 2020 que fue
el año de la pandemia en el que tuvimos
que recluirnos en nuestras casas que
muchas compartimos con Quienes son
nuestros agresores o Con quienes han
agredido el número de feminicidios
anuales en Ciudad de México solamente
subió a 82 feminicidios a lo largo del
año y si lo comparamos con las
sentencias condenatorias que llegan para
este mismo delito la cifra es mucho
menor Entonces en ese sentido también
este tipo de movilizaciones como ni una
menos la abrillantada no me cuidan me
violan y muchas otras consignas que hay
dentro del movimiento para detener la
violencia contra las mujeres han servido
para fortalecer que no es suficiente
actuar cuando ya el feminicidio se
ejecutó sino desde la prevención y
cambiando desde antes la violencia
estructural que solventa que haya
feminicidios Día tras día es decir la
violencia familiar la violencia
institucional la desigualdad social la
precarización y la el empobrecimiento de
las mujeres todo el estigma que existe
alrededor de aborto son muchas las
causas que contribuyen a que diariamente
la violencia feminicida siga escalando y
que las violencias se sigan
reproduciendo y lleguen a niveles tan
altos como un feminicidio pero si la
violencia feminicida ha seguido
escalando como usted misma lo dice y
especialmente como se vio durante la
pandemia Entonces cómo ha contribuido ni
una menos a ese cambio cultural y si ha
habido un cambio cultural Por qué
aumentan los feminicidios
es un fenómeno bastante interesante
porque también nosotras observamos que
por ejemplo en marzo que es el mes en
que se celebra el Día Internacional de
la mujer más bien el que se conmemora el
número de agresiones de violaciones y de
feminicidios aumenta exponencialmente
durante el mes de marzo entonces También
estamos en investigaciones respecto a
Por qué este fenómeno que implica que
nosotras seamos más partícipes en
nuestros procesos de Justicia que seamos
más conscientes de los procesos de
violencia y que se tengamos más
herramientas para atravesarlos y para
evitarlos enoja y molesta dentro de la
sociedad que nosotras estemos
organizadas y que estemos listas para
enfrentar estas violencias y lo que ha
tenido como consecuencia es más
violencia no como no no les Es agradable
que desde nuestro papel de mujeres y de
sí de ser como discriminadas
constantemente en el espacio público
Ahora nos apropiamos de esos espacios y
exijamos desde nosotras la justicia
Cristina usted está de acuerdo con esto
de que digamos un poco la resistencia de
las mujeres y la exigencia de sus
derechos ha creado un contrabalance o
una reacción y ha aumentado el
feminicidio Por esto yo estoy de acuerdo
en cierto modo puede deberse a una
reacción por el hecho de que los grupos
de mujeres estamos mucho más visibles
estamos denunciandolo de manera mucho
más evidente y esto también genera una
serie de reacciones de la sociedad otra
de las causas a las que yo me sumaría
Más allá de lo que ya mencionó Brenda es
también el hecho de que precisamente el
hecho de que se entienda mejor de qué se
trata el feminicidio también puede
facilitar el hecho de que más casos sí
se coloquen en las estadísticas como tal
nosotros podemos pensar en el caso
colombiano en muchas organizaciones que
por muchos años vinieron hablando de
feminicidio pusieron este tema en el
radar lo en muchos casos en los que las
organizaciones llevaron unas cifras dado
que las cifras oficiales No reflejaban
esas realidades quizás el hecho con el
tiempo hayamos hecho más visible este
punto también ha hecho que las
autoridades comprendan mejor de qué se
trata el feminicidio y esto se empiece a
ver en las estadísticas más oficiales lo
que no quiere decir que sean menos casos
de los que están reportándose sino que
por el contrario los casos ocurren por
fuera del sistema y apenas el sistema
está empezando a reflejar la verdadera
crudeza de lo que ocurre con el
feminicidio sin embargo por ejemplo en
el caso de Colombia en el año 2022 se
habla de 619 feminicidios las mismas
organizaciones dicen hay muchos casos
adicionales de los que podemos no
estarnos enterando pero que precisamente
porque en el hecho de que las
organizaciones denunciaron que es un
feminicidio exigieron una ley en ese
sentido y por eso tenemos la ley Rosa
Elvira que es la 1761 del 2015 con estos
procesos lo que estamos haciendo es
logrando que esos casos que no salían a
la luz ahora se conozcan se entiendan
como feminicidios y se procesen como tal
Y aún nos queda una brecha Porque muchos
autoridades judiciales muchos
funcionarios No necesariamente han
acogido este tipo de directrices Y
todavía muchos casos pueden estar por
fuera entonces creo que se puede deber a
esos fenómenos concurrentes el hecho de
que sea más visible y haya una reacción
violenta por el hecho de que las mujeres
la denuncian pero por el otro lado el
hecho de que el trabajo de las
organizaciones ha hecho que muchos casos
que antes no estaban en las estadísticas
Ahora sí aparezcan oficialmente en las
cifras y precisamente una de las
intenciones de ni una menos en todos los
países de América Latina ha sido
impulsar tener datos concretos sobre los
feminicidios esa ha sido una de las
luchas y una de las líneas de batalla
más duras que se han dado Le quiero
preguntar a usted Cristina Por qué es
tan difícil encontrar datos certeros de
los feminicidios bueno primero porque la
definición misma del feminicidio tomó un
tiempo para que se tome en cuenta y para
que las autoridades la acepten no hasta
muchos años por muchas décadas muchos
grupos de mujeres tuvieron que
enfrentarse a los debates de no existe
tal cosa como un feminicidio porque a
nadie la matan por ser una mujer
Y creo que eso pasa por el hecho de que
se desconozca la discriminación
estructural de las mujeres cuando una
persona empieza a conocer cómo se
empieza a dar en todos los aspectos de
la vida una serie de discriminaciones
que nos excluyen de los ámbitos
laborales educativos que nos excluyen de
los escenarios de poder de la dirección
de las empresas de otros aspectos es
cuando se empieza a entender mejor por
qué la discriminación puede terminar en
violencia y porque un feminicidio es la
forma más clara de la expresión de esa
violencia entonces creo que ha habido un
un camino como sociedad para poder
comprender que un feminicidio como un
Digamos como una definición como un
concepto existe y que se debe hacer
discriminación estructural Todavía
existe una serie de resistencias yo creo
que muchas organizaciones han hablado de
esto por años y todavía nos encontramos
en escenarios en los que tenemos que
volver a las explicaciones iniciales de
Oigan esto ocurre por estas razones
estas son algunos indicadores que nos
llevan a hablar de un feminicidio
entonces Todavía existe una serie de
resistencias que tienen que ver con esa
discriminación misma no el hecho de que
No necesariamente lo que nosotros
venimos denunciando tenga la suficiente
credibilidad para un sector que que
considera que estamos exagerando que
creemos que estamos haciendo como
demasiado ruido con un tema que para
ellos nos convenza entonces creo que al
final las estadísticas la evidencia lo
que hemos venido estudiando por años con
la experiencia de las organizaciones cae
por su propio peso y ha sido ya
incorporado por muchos de los estados a
través de normativas y leyes que les
exigen una serie de obligaciones frente
a las mujeres afectadas con la violencia
pero todavía nos faltará una brecha de
lograr que toda la sociedad esté en la
misma línea y sienta la misma
importancia que nosotros le queremos
poner frente a esta problemática tan
grave usted habla de discriminación
estructural y obviamente desde el
principio la relacionado con los
feminicidios yo tengo una duda al
respecto y es la cepal explica que la
mayoría de víctimas de feminicidio son
niñas y jóvenes que tenían entre 15 y 29
años Brenda yo le quiero preguntar en
los casos de los feminicidios por qué
esta violencia extrema se concentra
especialmente en las más jóvenes
bueno es como lo menciona Cristina es
violencia estructural que se sigue
solapando y fundamentando desde todos
los aspectos en donde nos relacionamos
en nuestra vida pública y nuestra vida
privada eso recae en que justo cuando
empezamos a tener estas relaciones que
sean entre nuestros familiares o Con
quienes decidimos relacionarnos sexo
afectivamente no estamos como en núcleos
que permitan un desarrollo y relaciones
de bienestar sino que al contrario
estamos rodeadas de contextos de
desigualdad de precarización donde la
violencia es pan de cada día y las
relaciones se construyen dentro de ese
mismo contexto por lo tanto las
relaciones se van a desarrollar de la
misma manera también estadísticamente
Quiénes ejercen esta violencia
feminicida son conocidos son Quienes son
las parejas de estas mujeres sus
familiares Con quienes viven y eso
también implica que el feminicidio tenga
que ver con las cuestiones de género y
con cómo estas relaciones que
establecemos en nuestra vida cotidiana
afectan y repercuten en nuestra vida
como mujeres es decir
no se está dando esa particular atención
en Qué contextos es en que se está
ejerciendo la violencia feminicida hace
mujeres racializadas de clase media de
clase trabajadora que viven en contextos
muy precarizados de desigualdad social
como lo decía hace rato en 2020 volver a
nuestros hogares implicó que muchos
tenían que compartir casa con los
agresores Y eso hacía que la violencia
estuviera mucho más presente y fuera más
letal que en aquellas ocasiones cuando
se puede salir del hogar y la violencia
no es un continuo de veinticuatro horas
también como lo comentaban en cuanto a
datos estadísticos en México Igualmente
se tuvo este hashtag nosotras tenemos
otros datos Porque el estado se negaba a
reconocer la violencia feminicida que
existía y que se seguía dando aún en el
contexto de pandemia y aún cuando han
dicho que bastaba con la tipificación
del feminicidio para que el fenómeno
disminuyera como dice Cristina la
tipificación de feminicidio es reciente
y ha costado que se admita como un
delito aparte del homicidio y que se
distingan las los sesgos de género que
implican las muertes violentas de las
mujeres México tiene al menos dos
sentencias condenatorias por parte de la
Corte Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
respecto a violencia contra mujeres y
violencia feminicida entonces en esos
contextos es muy fácil que la violencia
feminicida siga replicando y sigue
encontrando en la violencia
institucional un paraguas de Cuidado
para seguir siendo impune
usted menciona reiteradamente la
pandemia Y es que ONU dice que el hogar
es el lugar más peligroso para las
mujeres de 81.000 feminicidios que
registró ONU en todo el planeta en 2021
45.000 fueron cometidos o por las
parejas de las mujeres o por sus
familiares y las estadísticas en
Argentina es que siete de cada diez
homicidios ocurren dentro del hogar en
el caso de México Brenda como la
pandemia disparó los feminicidios y la
violencia extrema contra las mujeres Y
qué ha pasado desde entonces desde que
recuperamos el espacio público y
volvimos a salir
lo que pasó en la pandemia fue que los
feminicidios se dispararon como mencioné
feminicidios durante el año 2020 tan
solo en Ciudad de México y lo que hizo
el estado fue decir que no estaba
pasando que las cifras eran menores y
que justo nosotras desde los movimientos
feministas y de acompañamiento a
víctimas estábamos exagerando las
estadísticas eso implicaba que la medida
de volver a los hogares Y esto de decir
en tu casa está segura y seguro era
simplemente una cosa que implicaba el
estar seguro en cuanto a una pandemia o
a un virus que estaba en el aire en las
calles Pero dentro de los hogares
teníamos más peligros que implicaban
esta violencia feminicida a la que
fuimos expuestas pues la el recluirnos
en nuestras casas era una medida sin
perspectiva de género que no consideraba
que la violencia se ejerce dentro de los
hogares aún sabiendo que las el delito
que más se denuncia de de los delitos de
género violencia familiar es decir que
que se desarrolla dentro de nuestras
familias en el hogar
o por Quienes son como miembros de
nuestras familias y lo que ha pasado con
la pandemia también fue que te
fortalecieron las redes de apoyo y de
acompañamiento entre mujeres y Víctimas
de violencia lo que ha traído también ni
una menos Ni una más y otras consignas
es el acompañamiento entre mujeres para
hacer frente a la violencia feminicida
el estado por ejemplo con la pandemia
intentó decir que las cifras eran
menores pero justo esta organización de
mujeres permitió hacer saber que las
cifras tenían que corregirse y que eran
mayores Pues estábamos haciendo
investigación aún en la pandemia y aún
desde nuestros hogares estábamos
acompañando víctimas y protegiéndonos
entre nosotras ya sea a través de redes
sociales con líneas de apoyo a la
distancia y con muchas otras medidas que
se tuvieron que tomar desde su sociedad
civil para hacer frente a la violencia
Cristina Le quiero preguntar si estos
fenómenos de los que nos habla Brenda en
México se han visto en Colombia y en el
resto de la región concretamente si las
redes de apoyo se han fortalecido desde
la pandemia Y si en Colombia y en la
región también ha habido actos por parte
de los gobiernos para negar o disminuir
las cifras de feminicidios sí sin duda
Hay un fortalecimiento de las de las
redes de apoyo que de por sí venían Ya
creándose hace mucho tiempo y que sin
duda en Colombia ya tenían una base
gracias a las organizaciones de sociedad
civil que habían venido acompañando el
tema por muchos años no en este tema hay
que resaltarlo y hay que decirlo
claramente las organizaciones de
sociedad civil por muchos años han
sostenido la atención de las víctimas y
han reemplazado al estado en muchísimos
casos en la región terminan reemplazando
las labores que se deberían haber
previsto por las autoridades tanto
judiciales como de salud y en todos los
ámbitos del estado por lo tanto en el
caso de la pandemia al igual que lo que
Comenta Brenda en México
hubo una alerta un llamado de parte de
las organizaciones a la preocupación del
hecho de que las cuarentenas estrictas
se hagan sin tomar medidas de
acompañamiento a las mujeres y las niñas
que estaban en casa y que nuevamente
estaban conviviendo con sus agresores
esto hizo que en muchos casos por
ejemplo se tomen algunas medidas como
facilitar los canales de denuncia que No
necesariamente significó desarrollar
unos canales de atención efectivo es
decir se aumentaron canales de denuncia
No necesariamente Se tomaron medidas
para poder responder a esas denuncias y
eso fue una de las principales
dificultades en la pandemia en el caso
de la pandemia también se ve que después
de que se retoma el digamos el espacio
público en el 2021-2022 se sigue
presentando el incremento en muchos
casos se puede deber al hecho de que
durante la pandemia hubo dificultades en
la denuncia es decir se incrementó la
violencia pero no Se recibieron el mismo
número de denuncias porque no habían las
mismas facilidades o no se contaba las
herramientas para hacerlo y apenas
durante el 2021 Y veintidós empezamos a
ver el impacto en las cifras de esas
cosas que no se pudieron denunciar
durante la parte más compleja de la
pandemia entonces sin duda ha habido una
una un trabajo muy importante de las
organizaciones de sociedad civil en
llevar sus propias cifras y confrontar
con aquellas cifras oficiales del estado
y exigir del Estado una respuesta que
realmente de cuenta de cómo se da el
fenómeno en el caso por ejemplo de
Colombia recientemente se adoptó una
directiva por parte de la fiscalía
general de la nación la directiva cuatro
del 2023 que establece unos parámetros
claros de cómo los fiscales deben
realizar la investigación de los delitos
de feminicidio y en esos casos por
ejemplo resalta como estos entidades y
estas autoridades judiciales tienen las
obligaciones de debida diligencia
reforzada esto quiere decir que si uno
conoce un caso los fiscales deben actuar
por su propia cuenta es decir No esperar
a que llegue una denuncia sino actuar de
oficio y que tienen que partir de la
presunción de que se trata de un
feminicidio y a menos que tengan
elementos suficientes para descartar
solo en ese caso no usar la tipificación
esto es un paso muy importante porque va
a permitir que cada vez más
investigaciones se abran con el caso y
se permita que los fiscales tengan un
mejor conocimiento de cómo deberían
detectar esas señales de que se trata de
un feminicidio Entonces estos son pasos
de todas maneras sabemos que la
implementación va a haber unas brechas
pero sin duda el hecho de que las
organizaciones hayan estado de cara al
Estado confrontando que esta situación
es importante que es un fenómeno al que
debemos poner la atención ha resultado
en una serie de medidas que ahora las
mismas organizaciones retomamos para
poder implementar en la práctica y
Cristina qué tan preparado está el
sistema judicial de América Latina para
tipificar un feminicidio bueno sin duda
los casos por ejemplo que mencionó
Brenda son importantes el caso de campo
algodonero en la Corte Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos es absolutamente
importante porque sin duda habría una
línea jurisprudencial en donde deja una
serie de medidas claras para los Estados
no solamente el hecho de que hay una
debida diligencia es decir los estados
deben encargarse de realizar la
investigación tomando en cuenta Esta
discriminación estructural y Cómo
influye en el resultado de la muerte
violenta de las mujeres Cómo ese
contexto estructural también influye en
la falta de atención en la negación de
la credibilidad de los testimonios de
las víctimas en la falta de urgencia en
la búsqueda de las mujeres que están
desaparecidas por ejemplo entonces este
esta serie de estándares aclaran que los
estados tienen esa serie de obligaciones
que no solamente van a la atención sino
también en la prevención y en la
atención de las mujeres que han
sobrevivido que han sido Víctimas de una
tentativa o sus familiares que también
son Víctimas de feminicidio entonces hay
una serie de estándares que nos dejan
claras las obligaciones Pero nuevamente
se necesita una serie de medidas en la
implementación que requieren una
voluntad política y por una voluntad
administrativa y en general grande de
los estados que por lo general las
organizaciones seguimos reclamando
ustedes a lo largo de la conversación ya
han mostrado algunos de los avances no
solo de ni una menos sino de las
organizaciones que han luchado por los
derechos de las mujeres y que van más
allá del movimiento ni una menos por
ejemplo que los estados documenten
fielmente los feminicidios que el
sistema judicial aprenda a tipificarlos
a fortalecido las redes de apoyo entre
las mujeres esto ha permitido por
ejemplo un acompañamiento durante la
pandemia y post pandemia pero no solo
esto ha provocado el movimiento ni una
menos y las organizaciones feministas
sino que también vino la marea verde
acompañada por ni una menos y comenzó
una presión en toda América Latina para
legalizar el aborto así en diciembre de
2020 en Argentina se aprueba la ley de
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo que
permite el embarazo el aborto en todas
las mujeres antes de la semana 14 de
gestación luego en 2021 en septiembre de
2021 en México se despenaliza el aborto
como un crimen Brenda qué impactos trajo
esto al país
bueno nosotras todavía no tenemos todo
el país despenalizado nosotras tenemos
en Ciudad de México despenalizado Hasta
las doce semanas y en otros estados
También tenemos despenalizado hasta doce
semanas y en algunos otros con causales
que todavía como permiten el acceso a
aborto en ciertas condiciones ya sea
como por violación o en algunos casos
causados salud es decir que se ponga en
riesgo la salud de la de la persona que
está embarazada para nosotras Qué ha
significado como la marea verde desde
balances somos parte de marea verde aquí
en México es una alianza con otras
organizaciones que también trabajan el
tema de aborto y que también luchamos
como día con día para garantizar el
acceso a los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos que debemos tener todas y
todas como garantizados para poder
desarrollar nuestra vida de manera plena
y en bienestar y nosotras como
acompañantes de aborto y acompañantes de
violencia como también ha sido
significativo poder
que hasta las doce semanas no es
suficiente no como mencionas en
Argentina está hasta las 14 semanas el
acceso y también que el hecho de que
estés penalizado no garantice el acceso
es decir las instituciones de salud al
menos en Ciudad de México y en algunos
otros estados tienen el acceso en el
papel pero cuando tú acudes a los
servicios de salud Te niegan el servicio
la atención es muy muy lenta tienes que
esperar muchísimo tiempo y tratándose de
aborto y de tener un límite de el acceso
hasta la semana doce punto seis pues no
tenemos tiempo para estar como esperando
a ver que nos den o no el acceso
entonces también parte del trabajo de
las organizaciones de la sociedad civil
es por un lado exigirle al Estado que
garantice que en los servicios de salud
se dé el acceso pero también nosotras
poder facilitar el acceso a quienes lo
solicitan y no tienen como el tiempo
para estar esperando que el estado
decida darnos el acceso el acceso es una
de las discusiones también en cuanto al
aborto en Colombia y simplemente para
sumarle a los casos que ya había
mencionado anteriormente luego de que se
produjo el caso en Argentina y en México
en Ecuador se permitió el aborto en 2022
en casos en los que la mujer resulta
embarazada por violaciones y en Colombia
se despenalizó el aborto hasta la semana
24 también en febrero de 2022 desde
antes estaba despenalizado en tres casos
violación de la mujer malformación del
feto y cuando pusiera en riesgo la salud
de la madre Le quiero preguntar Cristina
Cuál ha sido la discusión sobre el
acceso a un aborto seguro Y qué ha
pasado desde 2022 cuando se despenalizó
hasta la semana 24 bueno para nosotros
es un tema muy cercano en el centro de
derecho reproductivos porque somos parte
del movimiento causa justa y fuimos una
de las organizaciones demandantes que
buscó esta despenalización en en
Colombia
Yo creo que el debate que se dio en
Colombia durante la discusión de de la
demanda de causa justa fue bien
interesante en especial porque tiene una
relación muy clara con el movimiento de
ni una menos y es llevar la discusión
hacia la dignidad y la autonomía de las
mujeres no la la concepción de las
mujeres como ciudadanas plenas y ese fue
uno de los de las premisas a partir de
las cuales el movimiento Se movió
mostrando como el hecho de que todavía
exista un delito que limita
particularmente a las mujeres y sus
decisiones frente a su proyecto de vida
es una forma de dejarnos como en una
ciudadanía menos importante que la de
los hombres o de otras personas en la
sociedad Y a partir de esa de esa
premisa Por supuesto que eso impacta
otros puntos como es el hecho de tener
derecho a una vida libre de violencias
entonces creo que para nosotras esa
conexión en Cómo las mujeres debemos ser
ciudadanas plenas y deberíamos tener
acceso a todo aquello a lo que las demás
personas tienen en las sociedades
importantes fue un punto muy importante
dentro del debate y dentro de la
discusión para nosotras el el punto o el
objetivo era la eliminación completa del
delito nosotros creemos como movimiento
que no debería ningún tipo de
penalización y que este es un tema que
debería regularse exclusivamente desde
el sistema de salud pero en las
discusiones de la corte la corte decide
este límite de 24 semanas con el que
estamos trabajando en la implementación
Y creemos que es un avance sin duda
importantísimo ya hemos podido ver en la
práctica cómo existen menos barreras que
antes antes los prestadores cuando
existían las causales quizás tenían la
posibilidad de decir no voy a certificar
y por lo tanto si no tienes el
certificado no tienes el requisito para
Acceder al al caso si denuncias una
violencia sexual quizás para mí está
denuncia no tiene valor y voy a poner
una barrera mientras que ahora como se
trata de la mera voluntad de la mujer
con un consentimiento informado debe
bastar para acceder
esto significa no significa tampoco que
automáticamente todos los problemas y
las barreras estén solucionadas pero sin
duda si hay unos pasos adelante y hemos
podido ver como cada vez más mujeres
acuden al sistema de salud y han
obtenido una respuesta más favorable Más
allá de que las barreras existan aún
Cristina muy brevemente Aprovechando que
ustedes del centro de derecho reprodu y
que tiene también una visión más
latinoamericana Le quiero preguntar cuál
ha sido el impacto de ni una menos y las
organizaciones feministas en países
donde por ejemplo el aborto está
totalmente restringido como en El
Salvador donde se penalizan incluso
abortos naturales espontáneos o en Haití
Honduras Nicaragua y República
Dominicana donde el aborto está
totalmente prohibido creo que hay una un
punto muy importante y es que se ha
creado una conversación regional más
profunda no significa que antes no se
hablaba entre los países pero sin duda
ahora es un tema mucho más visible
internacionalmente y hay una serie de
llamados y movimientos sociales
nacionales diciendo bueno nuestras
hermanas colombianas lo lograron
nuestras hermanas argentinas están en
esto Por qué nosotros tenemos que
enfrentarnos a una criminalización total
y ese diálogo entre los movimientos es
extremadamente importante porque lleva
más allá las peticiones que todo el
tiempo el movimiento feminista estuvo
haciendo esto significa que cada vez hay
un mejor desarrollo de estos movimientos
sociales y hay una exigencia mucho más
clara a los Estados y sus obligaciones
lastimosamente Ya se nos está acabando
el tiempo y debemos ir redondeando
nuestras ideas Brenda Cuál es su
conclusión de qué ha pasado en estos
ocho años de ni una menos Y si el
movimiento sigue vivo o no y que se
puede esperar a futuro
Bueno mi conclusión es que justo como ni
una menos y otras consignas han servido
mucho para poner sobre la mesa toda la
violencia de la que somos víctimas las
mujeres y también ha servido para
visibilizar como la organización de
mujeres feministas puede también
garantizar el acceso a la justicia en
México Tenemos muchos casos entre ellos
tenemos a la señora irinea Buendía que
justo por la lucha en la búsqueda de
justicia de su hija Mariana Lima Buen
día que fue asesinada también por su
pareja sentó un presidente en la suprema
corte de justicia de la nación para que
todos los muertes violentas de mujeres
sean investigadas como un feminicidio
desde balance y desde varias otros con
movimientos La Apuesta es que no solo
nos sentemos a esperar que el estado
garantice justicia o que se penalicen y
se
creen como sentencias y castigos más
altos sino que también te trabaje en la
atención y en la prevención es decir que
no apostemos todo en el punitivismo y
que también construyamos redes desde
mujeres que apuesten como por el
antiponitivismo es decir que no todo y
todas las soluciones que estemos
buscando sean cárcel sino también
reconocer que desde los movimientos de
mujeres feministas y En búsqueda de
Justicia se han logrado establecer otros
caminos para cuidarnos entre nosotras y
para garantizar que nuestra vida sea
libre de violencia Gracias y Cristina
Cuál es su conclusión Bueno creo que es
un largo camino que se ha recorrido sin
duda estas movilizaciones han
incrementado las personas preocupadas y
que entienden sobre este tema y
esperemos que esa conversación continúe
en la región y sin duda también pensar
en que también tenemos que ver Nuevos
Horizontes en esta misma discusión por
ejemplo temas que se nos quedan
pendientes los feminicidios que tienen
una base racista los feminicidios contra
niñas y adolescentes y en general Cómo
cambiar esas ideas tradicionales que
hacen que estas violencias se sigan
presentando entonces hay un un gran
camino recorrido sin duda Hay que
celebrar que cada vez la sociedad está
más consciente estos temas pero todavía
nos quedan una serie de medidas por
tomar y sin duda el movimiento estará
allí para hacerlo y así lo Seguiremos
aquí en France 24 por supuesto Cristina
Rosero abogada senior del centro de
derecho reproductivos y Brenda Velázquez
Montiel de la organización feminista
mexicana balance hace Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos así llegamos al final de
nuestro programa En nombre del equipo
técnico les agradezco por estar aquí en
France 24 la producción de este debate
estuvo a cargo de Luis Fernando Montes y
la de los invitados la tuvo Tania
Herrera ustedes pueden seguir comentando
en nuestras redes sociales y los invito
a que sigan conectados con Flash 24
[Música]